we just published the list of america's
richest
self-made women forbes has a very
specific definition
for self-made which other people
sometimes disagree with but
our definition of self-made is did you
get to your fortune through your own
efforts
as opposed to inheriting it for someone
else so the women on this list
are entrepreneurs founders of companies
celebrities
artists authors this is the seventh
annual list
that forbes has done of self-made women
we have a hundred people on the list
and we are basically capturing
their net worth using stock prices from
early july
for private companies on the list we
value those private companies as
if they were public as we've been seeing
you know for our billionaires list that
we put out in april we had
you know practically a new billionaire
every day for the for the past year
we have a number of new billionaires on
on this list we had 26 billionaires
this year out of 100 people most ever
from the years we've been doing this
self-made room list
and of the notable new billionaires one
is
rihanna the singer who's also an
entrepreneur
she became a billionaire because we got
new information
on her ownership of this fenty
beauty cosmetics line that she is
partnered with a french
luxury goods company lvmh she owns 50 of
that company which has
close to 600 million dollars in revenues
estimated and she's got a lingerie
company savage by fenty
which also raised new money at a higher
valuation the combination of those two
things put her over a billion dollars
for the first time
another new billionaire ann majeski
behind the company
23andme that people may know you spit
into the tube and it tells you
something about your your heritage and
some of your health risks
that company went public with they
merged with a blank check company a
special purpose
acquisition company um a few months ago
and her ownership in that company made
her
a billionaire we had 15 newcomers this
year
a pretty big batch one of the newcomers
this year
is dolly parton very well known singer
and actor and philanthropist
and investors she's got part of
dollywood an amusement park that's named
after her
and we were able to value her stake in
that plus her earnings
for years of singing we got dolly parton
on the list
at an estimated 350 million dollars some
more interesting newcomers
the co-founders of a medical scrubs
medical gear company called figs went
public
in the spring and two women trina spear
and heather hassan
co-founded that company and our co-ceos
and they're both newcomers to the list
their medical gear is a little bit more
stylish and
different colors and super popular with
many of the first responders who's been
helping out with healthcare during the
pandemic
another interesting newcomer is gail
becker from
a company called caulipower gail's
children
had celiac disease and couldn't eat
gluten and she came up with
a cauliflower-based pizza dough which
her kids loved and then she turned that
into a company
and now caulipower's frozen cauliflower
pizza crusts are in
stores all over the country diane
hendricks
is number one on the list yet again
she and her husband her late husband i
should say founded a
roofing company abc supply which is now
one of the largest
roofing companies in the country and
she's now with an estimated 11 billion
dollars
which is the first self-made woman to be
worth more than 10 billion dollars in
the united states
as we've seen with the stock markets in
general
it's been a record year for so many
stocks
the run-up in in the value of stocks
also pushed up the value of a lot of the
fortunes of the women on this list so
all together
they're worth 118 billion dollars these
100 women which is
31 more than last year when we did this
list
we saw some companies that went public
which
helped push up the networks of some
folks we saw some companies merge
with a special purpose acquisition
company a spac
and that helped push up some net worths
and then we got new information on
people like rihanna which helped
push up but her net worth but in general
stocks have been on a tear
and we saw that in the run up in the
value of a lot of these women's fortunes